hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel heute habe ich eine tolle advents
torte für euch oder auch eine
weihnachtskarte
und zwar habe ich hier eine mond orte
gefüllt mit damit seiner kirche im
bareinlage und einer richtig leckeren
sahne creme und hier oben drauf sind
kleine weihnachtswichtel ich find die
total süß ihr müsst ihr natürlich nicht
machen aber die sind oft teil schnell
hergestellt
ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal den montag
machen und zeige ich dafür mal kurz die
zutaten für den teig brauche ich drei
150 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
eine prise salz einem halben teelöffel
zimt eine unbehandelte zitrone 150
milliliter buttermilch und 150
milliliter sonnenblumenöl 25 grad
panaroma für 225 gramm mehl einen halt
teelöffel backpulver 50 gramm haselnüsse
und 125 gramm ohne das ist jetzt ein
ganz einfacher rührteig deswegen jetzt
erst einmal die eier in die röhre
gemeinsam mit dem zucker und dem man in
extrakt und auch sind und salz können
schon dazu und jetzt wird die masse etwa
vier bis fünf minuten auf höchster stufe
cremig verrührt und in der zeit werde
ich schon mal den mond fein mahlen
das geht jetzt in der gewürzmühle ganz
gut und falls ihr keine gewürzmühle habt
nehmt ihr einfach schon bereits gemacht
gemahlenen bohnen und die haselnüsse
werde ich auch fein hacken
wenn die eier machte dann schön cremig
ist kombis die flüssigkeiten dazu also
guter mensch und öl bei niedriger stufe
einfach kurz einrühren und dann kann ich
bereits mehl und backpulver mischen und
auch dazu 7
und kann das ganze mit den restlichen
zutaten einfach kunden erhöhen
jetzt kann ich den teig in eine backform
einzeln und zwar möchte jetzt für eine
blumenform entschieden habt ihr auf der
dauer bugdoll und auf meinen
perforierten backblech und kühlt es
jetzt hier ein
ihr könnt aber auch falls jetzt keine
blumenform habt einfach eine runde form
nehmen also einem runden parkring oder
eine springform bei der spring
vermissten uhr beachten der teig backt
nicht so gleichmäßig durch und braucht
etwas länger im backofen
und sogar der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 30 35 minuten gebacken
der teig ist jetzt schon abgekühlt und
jetzt kann ich bereits die füllung
vorbereiten
zuerst kommt ihr eine fruchtige füllung
drauf mit himbeeren und kirschsaft wir
können natürlich auch kirschen und
himbeeren oder ganz andere früchte was
ihr möchtet aber ich finde die
kombination schon richtig gut für die
füllung braucht ihr 300 milliliter
kirschsaft 300 gramm
tiefgekühlte himbeeren einem handelte
orange eine halbe zimtstange zweiten
habe ich hier noch mit drauf und zehn
gramm magazine oder ager nehme ich
zuerst einmal den saft der kommt jetzt
hier rein
da hat ihn dazu dann etwas glatte und
die mischung wird jetzt auf gekocht und
dann muss jetzt zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen damit die akademie ihre
wirkung entfalten kann
und da kommen die jetzt überraschen
schale mit dazu also eigentlich auch
harte schale nicht die ganze sache die
kamera passiert manchmal okay ich mache
das auch
was sagen wollte eigentlich ganz wichtig
dass die orange unbehandelt ist mein job
das alles hier
und dann kommen noch die gewürze mit
rein sind & medical und die muss ich
später aber bevor ich die torte fülle
wieder raus zwischen und während des zqp
62 minuten sprudelnd kochen lassen kann
ich hier schon mal den teig oder zehn
kuchen lösen
dann löse ich den kuchen mit einem
torten retter und schneidet einen dünnen
deckel ab damit der kuchen einfach schön
eben wird
und diese kugel rest könnt ihr dann
verwenden mit bisschen creme vermischen
und cake pops machen oder einfach so
kleine schneebälle des tigers später und
hier setze ich jetzt den bug ring noch
mal außen herum
nach zwei minuten fische ich jetzt hier
erstmal die gewürze raus und es riecht
jetzt auch richtig toll als ich meine im
prinzip habe ich jetzt einen
kinderwunsch eingestand wir können
natürlich auch glühwein zum beispiel
nehmen
schalte ich den herd aus und die gewürze
die müssen jetzt übrigens nicht
wegschmeißen die können wir jetzt solche
benutzen und in einem tee machen oder
einfach nochmal eine fraktion
kinderpunsch machen oder glühwein machen
da komme nämlich auch ganz viel
geschmack raus es gebe es die himbeeren
betreiben ohne glas bitte und rührt es
kurzum und warte jetzt einfach bis die
masse an verlieren
ich hab die maße jetzt umgefüllt damit
etwas schneller geht aber im prinzip
haben schon die gefrorene früchte dafür
gesorgt und jetzt kann ich das hier
schön einfüllen und stellen das dann für
30 minuten in den kühlschrank um dann
danach die ferne krieg zu machen
jetzt werde ich noch die sahne creme
vorbereiten und habe ich mir deine
sahnequark creme rausgesucht aber ihr
könnt auch zum beispiel stadt etwas
schmand nehmen oder auch mascarpone zum
beispiel aber ich finde quark passt
einfach geschmacklich sehr gut weil er
so ein bisschen sauer nicht schmeckt ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
füllung brauche ich 400 gramm
schlagsahne drei esslöffel butter zucker
500 gramm quark die orangen sich freund
verwendet habe und zehn teelöffeln
seiner partei nämlich zuerst einmal die
sahne
die kommt in eine rührschüssel dann geb
ich darin puderzucker mit rein und lasse
jetzt schon mal früheren und gewähren
dem röhren noch etwa die hälfte des
sunasset 1
ich kann noch ein bisschen orangenschale
abschreiben
und auch noch ein bisschen saft
auspressen da brauche ich jetzt nur etwa
bei befall telefon
und sobald die sahne und fast steif ist
gebe ich jetzt auch den quark dazu wie
kann man es natürlich auch nur
unterheben ist aber kein rechtliches
seiner fahrt mit dazu und die aufhorchen
schale und auch den saft und dann
einfach vorsichtig früheren dass die
krähen eben ganz fest wird aber nicht zu
lange sollen damit die sonne einfach
nicht gewinnen
mit streich sahne creme auf die firmware
creme oder himbeer masse
das mache ich jetzt gar nicht so glatt
denn später soll es so ein bisschen wie
eine schneelandschaft aussehen und die
torte stelle ich jetzt für etwa drei bis
vier stunden in den kühlschrank gekühlt
und ich werde jetzt aber noch ein paar
dekoration machen unsere kleine wichtel
sie dann oben in die torte reingesteckt
bzw
aufgestellt werden und die mache ich
jetzt aus modelle schokolade und habt
ihr etwa 110 gramm rote modell
schokolade hp weiter module schokolade
und dann noch etwas gelbe lebensmittel
verpasste und diese zucker augen und es
geht jetzt auch sehr schnell in dem das
t-modell ihr schokolade und ein ganz
kleines stück das ist schon ungefähr
etwas kleiner als wahllos groß bis zu
einer kugel und dann etwas länglich
geformt und es muss noch gar nicht so
genau sein und die wichtel müssen auch
alle gar nicht exakt genauso aussehen
wie der andere
dann formt ihr hier unten so eine kleine
mulde rein und könnte diese wichtel
mütze so ein bisschen nach oben hin
formen
dann nehme ich die weiße modelle
schokolade und forme kleine kugeln
die werden dann gleich drauf gesteckt
und zum drauf stecken nämlich jetzt
einfach so ein kleines modul ihr
werkzeug stich hier ein loch hinein und
kann es dann eben hier ausschließen
dieses hautfarbenes stück habe ich aus
weiß und rot gemischt und einfach ein
bisschen gelbe lebensmittel verpasste
eingemietet und daraus form ich jetzt
eine runde nase
jetzt kann ich schon die einzelnen teile
zusammenfügen und zwar lebt er jetzt
jeweils eine nase an den richter das
geht wenn die modelle corolla noch weich
ist ganz ohne kleber ansonsten nimmt
noch s-bahn kleber dazu dann die zwei
augen oben drauf und dann vorm ich noch
aus weißer modelle schokolade die weiße
umrandung und klebt sie nach außen
jetzt dekorieren wir die torte fertig
und zwar löse ich jetzt erst mal von der
wunderbar form
vom messe außenrum darüber richtig schön
abschluss und jetzt kommt noch ein
bisschen kopflos drauf das ist nämlich
die schneelandschaft was auch ganz gut
passen würde wären bc stücke zerkleinert
als schön kokos im mondpalast geschmack
denn auch sehr gut zusammen ich glaube
die tat erinnert geschmacklich so ein
bisschen an die türkische mond orte
und jetzt nach diesem wichtigen als er
ist natürlich ein paar zu viel gemacht
wollen jetzt möchte ich hier jeweils
allen reinsetzen oder setzte einfach
querbeet über die torte
kann ich die torte anschneiden dem uralt
ist leider noch nicht dabei ist noch mit
samira unterwegs aber heute dafür passen
probieren
hallo fragen sie einen so als ich
schneide jetzt ein großes stück raus
aber zum servieren würde ich jetzt hier
16 kuchen also tortenstücke machen weil
ansonsten ein stück zu viel wird also
war die durchschnitte das ganze stück
essen am ende ein großes stück weil ich
groß bin ja genau das sind und dann
guckt er so aus der schneelandschaft
verfahren bitte hochdeutsch oder war
christa thiel
bitte kein chronisch bin ich mal
gespannt
als einer der besten die ich je gegessen
habe mich ziemlich schön saftig die
creme lecker
geschwächte professionell wieder hoch
ich sag jetzt fahr schnell beleidigt er
später vor allem des kokons schnelles
pass war wohl zu montag heute ja also
falls ihr die torte nach machen wollt
ihr seht ihr noch mal von innen
ich finde die drei komponenten mohn
frucht und creme passen wirklich super
zueinander
die kleinen wissen sind natürlich das
i-tüpfelchen optisch und die schmecken
auch sehr gut weiter aus modelle
schokolade bestehen
und falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht einfach auf 6 - klopp der
eder stets noch mal für euch und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß danach
machen und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal bis dann